hey everyone its micromotor flows and
I'm shooting this quick video to explain
how to use order flow to find potential
reversals in the market I mean you know
to me this is one of the main benefits
of order flow is being able to read what
is happening in the market as it happens
and so you could determine if we're
going to turn at a certain level in the
market or are we going to just keep
going or we're gonna go sideways you
know I'm always looking for trading
opportunities and sometimes it's just
really obvious I think in the order flow
I mean lots of times its markets very
boring you know markets there people are
trading back and forth but there are
certain times in the market where things
just really jump out at you and you have
to know what to look for in order to
trade them I mean if you don't know what
to look for it's kind of pointless to
use order flow you know I mean I come
across people that you know they want to
use order flow but they don't want to
take the time to learn it or learn what
to look at you know it's kind of
pointless because you know it's not
something that you can just pick up by
staring at the screen oftentimes you
need someone to tell you you know what
to look for if you don't know what to
look for you know you're not going to
become any good at it
so before I jump in a brief disclaimer
this presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only should not
be considered a solicitation to buy or
sell a futures contract or make any
other type of investment decision
futures training contain substantial
risk and is not for every investor an
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that can be lost
without jeopardizing one's financial
security or lifestyle only risk capital
should be used for training only those
were sufficient risk capital should
consider trading passive warrants is not
necessarily indicative of future results
Kenny I always go through that because
you know I want people to realize there
is risk involved in trading know there's
money on the line and you know if you
know your name is mr. flush with cash
then you don't need to trade you know
you already got money but you know what
if you want to learn how to trade and
you know hopefully you know make a few
extra bucks here or there you know
supplement your income or or you know
make it your primary income you know I
know a lot of people that trade for a
living that's all they do so it can be
done and you know that's what I like to
do these presentations it's just you
know to give people a taste of you know
what's involved in trading and and the
work involved you know you're not gonna
see me
Oh a Ferrari you know the nicest car I
had was a BMW before but you know I
don't fly around in private jets I fly
commercial all right you know I mean I
saw these jokers on Instagram and
Facebook posting pictures of Ferraris
and all that stuff you know there's very
few real traders that actually live that
lifestyle you know the for the ones that
are good you know they don't do it for
necessarily the financial rewards
although I can't say that but in the
sense that they don't like the the
rewards that they get but rather you
know they get into trading because it's
something that stimulates them that that
it gets them to you know if it's
challenge for them you know it's like a
puzzle that they always want to be
solving so before I begin you know again
the tools in this presentation is the
order fools trader software and you know
full disclosure it's a software that I
sell but it the reason why I came up
with the order foolish trader software
years ago is is because you know I was
trading with a different volume
footprint chart but didn't really have
the information on there that I wanted
you know there's just the basic volume
footprint chart you know with with the
volumes that's on the bid and the offer
the Delta okay but you know I want to
take it further you know a bit further
because you know I'm a visual person I
like to look at a chart and see patterns
and you know certain setups instantly
like that the mind processes pictures at
a much faster rate than crunching
numbers or reading text so this is the
email is this is a one-minute chart you
know that's why I came up with soft boss
he came up with the software but you
know I took a software and built on it
to expand it into something that is
going to make my trading much better so
you know this is a minute chart this is
12:45 in the afternoon Chicago time
yesterday we're just sort of hanging
around here I'll go a little side dip
down and then we get this rally from 69
and a half basically up to 74 and a half
okay no on this rally this is just a
nice healthy five-point rally if you're
watching the deltas you know three
hundred forty three eighty two hundred
minus 58 minus eighty nine plus a
thousand minus seventy three plus 1 91
plus 64 minus 20 to plus six forty at
the
here sixty two twenty six seventy four
and three-quarters okay and on this move
up you see a lot of buying imbalances
see one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve basically
almost every bar every up bar has got
buying imbalances in there and obviously
it's mostly positive Delta's you have a
couple small negative Delta's - 58 - 73
- 22 but just because you got a bar with
negative Delta doesn't mean the move is
over those are smaller XI Delta numbers
and you know that tells me one of two
things one you know the the aggressive
selling you know even though it's there
isn't that strong and to those Delta
numbers are kind of neutral you know I
usually take numbers around fifty and
below as kind of neutral in the markets
you know I can go either way
spiciness and peace you know that could
be one trade a fifty lot and you know
you're looking at positive Delta so but
it was interesting because you know on
this move up again from this the swing
low here again you know new trading you
have to get to a point where you could
identify potential swing lows or
potential swing highs because what's
going to happen is you're going to rally
from a swing low to a swing high and
that's where you can get short you're
gonna be able to identify hey you know
what there's a potential turning point
in the market and that's what I want to
talk about here so why is this so
interesting here is what happens okay
you have this bar here three imbalances
very strong positive Delta and it comes
in this bar small negative Delta minus
seventy three and market doesn't sell
off well why should it just because you
have a red candle and negative Delta
there's nothing in there telling me that
hey you know what this market is
probably going to reverse here then we
go a little bit higher we get to the
swing high here at four and
three-quarters seventy four and
three-quarters and what happens okay on
the way up you got positive Delta plus
six forty you got eighty two 377 523 you
got three imbalances there and you got a
selling imbalance here 273 okay now it's
a minute base chart so keep in mind that
a new bar is gonna form when the minute
closes you know I like to look at range
based charts but I know a lot of traders
still use minute base charts you know I
want to use it for this example
and so what's happened is the market
opened up traded up to four and three
quarters some selling came in here to 73
the bar closed period closed it was 12
57 and 59 seconds okay we got to close
this bar next bar opens okay right here
right where we close this bar got two
more selling imbalances boom-boom it's
you know you so essentially you've got
almost a you know a spread out stack
selling imbalance right here 273 189 476
if you were to sort of merge those two
bars together again you know you're
trading a minute based chart so that's
why it's gonna pop you know spread out
like that okay and then it's a red bar
and look when you get down here
you got another sound imbalance 528
against nine you got a couple buying
imbalances but look at the delta minus
500 it's quite strong so you know take
into account everything that just
happened okay you had a rally a
five-point rally get a little aggressive
buying up here but then you hit this
high where's the follow-through buying
you got aggressive selling coming in as
you close in this bar the next bar opens
the aggressive selling is still there
pushes the bar lower we closed lower
strong negative Delta so you got your
swing high
you got aggressive selling coming in you
got stacks on and balance that split up
over two bars you got three imbalances
in this bar you got strong negative
Delta to me that's you know and it's
like so obvious that hey maybe we get a
little bit of a sell-off here you know
you should think about getting short
where are you gonna place your stop
you're just gonna place it above this
high here 75 so imagine you're getting
short at you know 3 and 3/4 somewhere or
you know 3 and 3/4 three and a half in
this bar right here and your stop is
just right here at 75
so you're risking what is that a point
and a half more or less
and look at the deltas it starts selling
off - 128 58 still kind of small - 100
but the bars you know another thing to
watch is also the point controls where's
the point controls well here they're all
even but they're gradually getting lower
and boom we sell off from the seventy
three and three-quarters seventy three
and a half area back down
he say you're risking you know not even
two full points in a point and a half
point three quarters and it just drops
off boom negative Delta's all the way
down all the way down all the way down
now I'm not saying you would have
shorted at three and a half and and you
know covered down here at the you know
at four even though here you have a
order flows divergence you have the
positive Delta and a bullish ratio you
know that's where you'd be covering your
trade down here I mean it that's where
you know it's me that's just I don't
know it just it's just one of those
things that just stand out you know the
other thing is is to keep an eye on is
the point of controls what's the point
of controls and the bars doing you know
if you know order flow you know one of
the basic things is point of controls
look for the point of controls on moves
lower your opponent controls should be
going lower right in this case he got
three lined up okay fair enough it's not
the end of the world
but then you know watch as you start
moving down lower point of control lower
point of control lower point of control
that's what happens in markets and
moving down you know you have lower
point of controls so this gave you a
nice low risk trade again your stop is
up here at five just above this high
because if that aggressive buying came
back in and we took off that high
there's no reason to be short at all and
then you can capture this whole move you
know if you're using some sort of moving
average where you're getting short you
know moving average you're gonna come in
here around seventy two that you're
getting short out of you know it's it's
stupid you're up here right as it
happens right here these two bars this
tells you there's a potential change in
the market your reversal is here and you
know it just sells off quite nicely boom
boom boom
you know three and a half seventy three
and a quarter all the way down to you
know 66 67 you know those are the trades
that you want to be looking for on a
daily basis okay so thanks for watching
this video you know if you're interested
in learning more about order flow
subscribe to my youtube channel I've got
a webinar coming up on Thursday April 26
I put the sign up link in the
description below if you want to if
you're interested to learn more about
order flow definitely attend it and even
if you can't attend it's definitely
worth
to sign up so at least it could be
alerted for the replay when it's
available I you know I cover stuff in
these webinars I don't normally cover
elsewhere so it's definitely something
to to watch so thanks everyone have a
great day
bye bye